hay dosis de sobra para todos los
estadounidenses pero apenas el 50% de la
población está totalmente vacunada eso
ya es más y como mencioné casi todos los
casos hospitalizaciones y muertes
debidas al kobe 19 son de personas no
vacunadas
para revertir la situación by then
anunció nuevas medidas obligación de
vacunarse para los casi 4 millones de
empleados federales quienes no obedezcan
la norma deberán someterse a test cada
semana retomar el uso de la mascarilla
mantener el distanciamiento social y no
podrán realizar viajes de trabajo una
medida que se extenderá a las empresas
contratistas con el estado
by then también instó al pentágono a
incluir el fármaco contra el cob y 19
entre las inyecciones obligatorias para
los miembros del ejército desplegados
por el mundo y pidió a los distritos
escolares instalar centros de vacunación
para inocular a los mayores de 12 años
además pidió a los gobiernos locales
dotar con 100 dólares del fondo de
recuperación a las personas que acudan a
vacunarse por primera vez y aseguró
financiar a las pequeñas y medianas
empresas que permitan a sus empleados ir
a vacunarse o incluso llevar a sus
familiares a hacerlo en horario laboral
miren esto no va de estados rojos y
azules es sobre vida y muerte su
decisión de no vacunarse impacta a los
demás los no vacunados esparcen el virus
según un estudio de la universidad de
chicago entre la población no vacunada
más de la mitad no cree en la eficacia
del fármaco contra las nuevas variantes